cbs news chief legal correspondent jan
crawford shares in our washington bureau
jan good morning to you as we get
your thoughts here one day later uh the
supreme court seems to be saying
basically here we're done
talking about abortion is that actually
the case is there reason to believe
this is the final word on the federal
level yeah i mean on the core right to
an abortion absolutely i mean the the
opinion uh really couldn't be more clear
i mean this court believes like a fair
number of legal scholars that roe versus
wade was basically just made up it was
wrong from the beginning there's nothing
in the constitution about a right to
abortion and coming in 1973 when a lot
of states were starting to liberalize
their laws and allow abortion the court
jumped in short circuited the political
process and said abortion was legal
nationwide the court says that just
inflamed the debate it's time to return
the issue on a right to abortion back to
the people's elected representatives in
the individual states what does that
mean i mean that means that if you want
to ban abortion in mississippi or all
those other states that christina just
mentioned that already are that's fine
there is no constitutional right women
have so the court is there's no role for
the supreme court to rule on it there
are other issues that the court could
take up that are related to abortion
access and i think you are going to see
some of those legal challenges play out
like whether states can ban access to
abortion pills or whether states can
prosecute people for going across state
lines to get an abortion i think you
could see some of those in the court but
not on whether or not states can ban or
greatly restrict it that's done
jan christina rafini seemed to suggest
or actually clarence thomas did in fact
go even further than that suggesting
that that things like uh contraception
and gay rights might also be impacted
later down the line what's what are the
chances of that actually happening i'd
say zero i mean this court even in the
opinion said uh it's hard to say how we
could be more clear that those cases are
not threatened or cast in doubt you know
justice thomas then wrote that separate
opinion where he says well i think they
you know might be but no one agreed with
him so he's out there on a trip of his
own uh he's one justice you had you know
the other four were like we don't agree
you know we're not on board with that
justice brett kavanaugh wrote a separate
opinion himself saying no no and so you
know if states do try to limit access to
contraception or limit you know gay
marriage that will go back into the
courts and that issue could come back to
the supreme court and there's probably
eight justices setting thomas aside that
would say those cases like we said in
dobbs are not implicated
jan a lot of the polling out there
showed that the court is more
conservative than americans even are
specifically when it comes to roe versus
wade and other issues might we now see
more calls to reform the court after
this decision possibly and i think
that's partly what was driving the chief
justice's concurring opinion he worries
about things like that as the chief
justice as you know he would have upheld
mississippi's 15-week ban
but he didn't think the court needed to
take the next step and overturn roe
versus wade in a 1992 subsequent case on
abortion rights so he wouldn't join
those five in overturning roe and i know
he has been quite concerned that you may
see calls to add uh more justices to the
supreme court or try to change the the
makeup of the supreme court i think that
was partly what was driving him kind of
the institutional his belief that this
could hurt his institutional integrity
but i think that's going to be a really
har you know tough road to hoe in
congress right now there's not uh
support right now to change the the
numbers of justices
all right jan we'll have to leave it
there a lot more debate on this subject